bonjour vincent drezet
merci beaucoup d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a vu bruxelles promet de mieux lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale elle a eu un
timing est un peu malheureux en retirant
ces trois pays de sa liste noire elle
les a retirés parce qu'ils ont promis de
s'engager à lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale or on y croit
en tout cas on est prié le creux de les
croire mais quand on regarde ce qui
s'est passé depuis maintenant presque un
quart de siècle depuis 1998 qui est
l'année où le cd eux a publié un rapport
sur la lgv ce qu'on appelle la
concurrence fiscale dommageable le mage
abl pardon depuis 1998 souvent des suffi
aux états de promettre qu'ils vont
coopérer pour être retirée des listes
noires même s'il le sait depuis quelques
années il ya quand même qu'on appelle
une évaluation
moralité on voit bien qu'on est au bout
de ces stratégies au bout de la
stratégie des listes noires puisqu'elles
ne sont accompagnées d'aucune sanction
puisque en plus elle ne comporte pas
l'ensemble des paradis fiscaux ça a été
dit le très justement dans le reportage
en octobre également d'une certaine
gouvernance fiscale mondiale ou parce
qu'il ya des affaires et donc une
pression d'opinion on prend quelques
mesures ne peuvent aujourd'hui qu'elles
sont inefficaces et l'a véritablement
une fois de plus parce que c'est une
affaire de plus malheureusement mais qui
portent en plus intéressantes on voit
que les mesures sont loin d'être
suffisantes et qu'il manque encore
beaucoup de volonté politique on
véritablement convaincre ce film en tout
cas le commissaire européen paolo
gentiloni lui a indiqué qu'une
proposition législative sera présenté
avant la fin de l'année
comment l'europe peut peut renforcer son
arsenal contre l'évasion fiscale avec
quels critères
alors il ya plusieurs choses a déjà le
plan législatif l'europe devrait
s'engager véritablement dans une
harmonisation fiscale par exemple de
l'impôt sur les sociétés elle quitterait
comment très contourner nouvelles d'hier
la fois parce qu'elle l'optimisation
fiscale agressive mais aussi à la fraude
le retour est par exemple toujours selon
destatis avoir un véritable régime
unifié amateurs de telus a investi
fraude à la table à 13 points tantôt
sein de l'union européenne ne serait ce
que sur le plan législatif réformes et
des appeaux qui sont aujourd'hui
contournez notamment les chaînes morel
et puis évidemment prendre des mesures
en matière de lutte contre la fraude
fiscale en clair attend 6 et la
coopération sa chute avait choqué
automatique d'information créée comme le
propose la belgique man un cadastre
financier mondial en tout cas européen
on savoir qui détient points en matière
de titres financiers et renforcer les
administrations fiscales et douanières
et judiciaires tant que ça n'est pas
fait et il y aurait beaucoup d'autres
mesures à prendre on peut difficilement
parler de réelle politique de combattre
l'évasion fiscale en tout cas la
publication de ces pandora paper
concernant les trois prendre 36
personnalités mises en cause ça a le
mérite en tout cas de faire bouger les
choses
alors on verra ce qui est presque depuis
2008 ya beaucoup d'affaires lorsqu'il ya
malheureusement sur l'optimisation
fiscale elle aussi sur la fraude fiscale
sur tous ces mécanismes qui à chaque
fois font apparaître les mêmes ressorts
c'est à dire une opacité le
contournement de l'impôt parfois même du
blanchiment bref les piments on réagit
on avait en france avec kevin et jaune
que la lutte contre l'évasion fiscale
était une des priorités en matière de
demande de justice fiscale donc parfois
ça mais les gouvernements à prendre des
mesures souvent trop timides lorsqu'il
faut souhaiter c'est qu'ils aient pas
les affaires qui vend qui se succèdent
parce que derrière les naseaux fiscal
est le bilan que l'on peut tirer qui
loin d'être satisfaisant des mesures qui
ont été prises c'est aussi une crise
démocratique qui est en train de se
nouer une perte de confiance est
finalement une dégradation du
consentement à pau ça c'est très grave à
la démocratie ce qui est effectivement
plusieurs dirigeants européens en
exercice qui sont concernés par ces
révélations ils ont pu échapper à la 10
qualité de leur pays ah mais aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'il risque finalement
alors ça dépend des états puisque chacun
est à saluer six stations en france il y
a deux types de sanctions dans ce
on fait l'objet d'un redressement fiscal
il ya des pénalités fiscales
c'est-à-dire une somme qui s'ajoute à
l'impôt que vous devez payer le
passionne que vous n'aimez pas payer
auparavant et puis il ya parfois des
sanctions judiciaires des sanctions
judiciaires de type au monde parfois des
peines de prison avec sursis elle et
force est de constater qu'il ya peu de
condamnations fermes tout simplement
parce que la grande fraude fiscale
échappent largement malheureusement la
détection à la contrôle fiscal en france
mais aussi dans d'autres états faute de
moyens le domaine législatif folle et
moi
l'enseignement de cette de cette affaire
c'est que malgré les quelques mesures
timides loin d'être efficace bon eh bien
ce phénomène continue une telle que le
effectivement le renforcement de
l'arsenal législatif le renforcement des
dispositifs anti fraude fiscale et aussi
des sanctions notamment des sanctions
judiciaires pourraient conditionner en
réalité pour promettre ce soir ce fléau
il faut agir sur tous les fronts
réformer la fiscalité mais c'est d'abord
le mot de trop ma raquette intensifier
la coopération et montrer que
l'administration fiscale et que la
justice sont là voilà ce match nul 0-0
parle d'évasion fiscale il ya aussi
l'évitement fiscal qui lui est souvent
monté d'ailleurs sur des bases tout à
fait légale est-ce que c'est pas là le
problème le plus compliqué à combattre
alors c'est vrai que les zones grises
dont entre l'optimisation aussi
agressive c'est à dire une forme
d'évitement légal vais pas le guide pour
faire court et la fraude fiscale mais en
étaient au moins lorsqu'on a les moyens
d'administration fiscales notamment de
creuser si j'ose dire et d'avoir
l'information on s'aperçoit que darren
légal et apparente il ya souvent en
complément du droit lui-même ski points
à 1003 où une fronde par exemple des
sociétés qui déposent leur bilan vous
avez les chiffres lorsque vous regardez
n'a pas d'activité petite activité
toujours en gros bénéfices patron
premiers kills
mais moi dire effectivement aussi d'une
exploitation imaginaire et fiscales des
textes de type conventions fiscales
internationales les régimes fiscaux
particuliers matière intellectuelle pas
être avant tout ça est objectivement si
complexe mais les règles sont complexes
parce que les états et sa politique
l'ont voulu c'est aussi quelque part le
produit d'une volonté politique qui a
laisser faire laisser des trous dans la
raquette si je dirais une lacune en
matière de numérique donc effectivement
il ya besoin de lui dire de grand
nettoyage au sens d'une grande forme on
espérait beaucoup dans les projets de
l'eau c'est dur on était très déçu
évidemment par l'impôt minimes à la
casse pour cent et on se dit que la
lutte contre la fraude fiscale va être
encore l'onu
andrezé pour votre éclairage ce matin
sur rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
économiste fiscaliste membres d'attac
également auteur du livre notre argent
public pour mieux vivre ensemble aux
éditions l'harmattan